oK you've now successfully used get to
merge some branches at this point you
might be wondering whether git can
always automatically determine how to
merge branches let's think this through
by taking a look at another simple
example in this example just like in the
last one the original file contains a
couple of lines a B and D remember these
are just stand ins for lines not the
content themselves again like in the
previous example
Jake's file and Rachel's file look a
little bit different at the end of the
day this time at the end of the day
Jake's file contains the lines a B Prime
and D where B Prime just stands for a
modified version of B and then Rachel's
file at the end of the day contains a be
double Prime again another modified
version of B but not the same one as
Jake's and D if it helps to think about
this in more concrete terms you can
imagine that this file is a recipe and
that B is a line that calls for
preheating the oven to 375 degrees then
B Prime for instance could call for
preheating the oven to 400 degrees and B
Double prime could call for 350 but
again this content really could be
anything just like you did in the last
exercise consider for each line whether
or not it should be in the final version
if you think it should be mark it as yes
if you think it shouldn't mark it as no
and if you don't think that we really
have enough information market is
unknown